[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started let's just pay the
bills right now walk to Main Street
boxing gym this is all the main street
fighters come from 100% as you can see
there's a lot of bags full size ring the
Olympic training a lot of Champions came
in and out of this place come here and
train young and old every bag imaginable
speed bag heavy bag full body bag full
size ring time bad talk with the King
man last night's fight well yesterday
afternoon's fight was fantastic now the
reason why I was in afternoon because it
was done overseas at Wembley Stadium
90,000 sellout ash actually it was
probably a little bit more because they
had some standing room there Anthony
Joshua there's a phenomena overseas the
level of draw that he's able to bring in
is insane I think this is his fourth
sellout stadium and congratulations to
and steel the heavyweight champion of
the world
missing one belt shout-out to Deontay
Wilder and like I thought I thought
youth will serve I thought that you
would be a little bit too much he would
be a little bit too strong a little bit
too long with the jab at the right hand
he would keep his distance I thought
that it will be drawn out though I
thought Povetkin
would actually work a little bit more
behind the jab draw it out a little bit
more but I've noticed something very
early on that AJ took away his jab early
on in the fight the fight ended in
seventh round KO for Joshua he hit
Povetkin with a fastball right hand off
of a lazy jab now remember the three P's
of boxing repeats professionalism polish
and poise
well all three was on display like I
said these are two champions one was a
former champion one is a current
champion these are two gold medalists so
what we got was a level of
professionalism that was outstanding I
mean you know I can do without tapping
the loves in between rounds basically
shaking hands and acknowledgement listen
before the fight great after a fight
fantastic but during the fight now I
want my my dogs to be dogs but Povetkin
won some early rounds going into the
seventh round I actually had it even to
be honest with you I thought Povetkin
landed a left left right hand to
Joshua's face in the first round and I
think he probably broke his nose or
either if he didn't break it full broke
it was probably fractured in some form
of fashion because he began to bleed
profusely so you know this is why I love
the sport because after all this
prognostications and you know sitting
there thinking we gonna feel is gonna go
this way it's gonna go that way
and what we think is gonna happen it's
always ultimately up to those two
fighters inside that ring you have the
greatest corner man you can have the
greatest training facility it all balls
down
mano a mano those guys fighting those
guys actually putting their life on the
line because it's it takes a sharpness
it takes a Polish it takes a certain
type of individual to walk through the
fire and dare to be great you understand
when you're stepping those in that ring
and those gloves are on you and you like
you're strapped in you're strapped in
it's like a roller coaster ride you are
strapped in
you have your mouthpiece on just six
weeks you slam into a wall you know
racecar driving technology yeah um and
you you have your hands strapped in the
gloves cuz you can't take them out all
right so that level of calm that must
come over you because you are about to
do combat with the person in front of
you and you must walk through that
person to achieve your gold
all right so in order to do something of
that nature it's a certain mind state
now to repeatedly do this this mind
state has to be a conscious effort so
you have to go through training camp to
build yourself up to the point that
you're able to fight so when you're in
that ring it's you versus him
no outside circumstances nothing is
going to change that fact now unlike
what golovkin did when he fought Canelo
when Canelo made a mistake golovkin
didn't make him pay hey Anthony Joshua
made sure that he made him pay in such
an immediate fashion he he'll serve he
had his high guard he didn't allow
Povetkin to establish the jab Alexander
tried his best and then he proceeded to
use right hands and hooks to work his
way in Anthony Joshua I await him by 23
pounds going into this fight okay and
that's really neither here nor there
both men over 200 pounds a 200-pound man
punching you in the face is very serious
okay
head body wherever he's gonna land it's
going to be felt you're gonna understand
what's happening there so what he needed
to do was establish the jab he abandoned
his jab and that is no fault on his part
actually Anthony Joshua helped him
abandon a jab by keeping a high guard
encountering every time his jab went
back so what Povetkin will do is leap in
with the left hook right hand because he
was successful with it um it was
somebody work put in but what you notice
was Joshua was putting in little work to
the head little work to the body going
for showing them faints once Joshua was
settled down into the fight then he
settled in around the sixth round
because I gave him the last two rounds
the first couple of rounds you know they
were going back to 12 so you know up
until then um like I said I had it tied
going into the seventh round and that's
when a knockout occurred I thought that
it wouldn't do that but it did it showed
me that poised he waited he struck and
he finished him he made sure he jumped
on him he's making sure he didn't crowd
his punches remember I told you the
punches will come clean remember I told
you the clenches if there was any will
be tight and concise remember I told you
two hooks two uppercuts everything would
be on display for you to see properly
all right
it wouldn't be messy it wouldn't be
sloppy you had the three P's on display
and it was beautiful
so now that we have this and you can see
Joshua got rid of the boogeyman a
Povetkin all right Deontay Wilder got
rid of the boogeyman and Ortiz there's
two boogeyman in the division all right
and the boogeyman was Luis Ortiz Deontay
Wilder knocked him out in a thrilling
fight and Anthony Joshua knocked out
Alexander Povetkin
the book man of the West in a dramatic
fashion to set it up and I wish this
fight was setting up the Deontay Wilder
Anthony Joshua fight but it's not
setting it up to be honest with you
because you have Deontay Wilder versus
Tyson Fury former champion who lost his
belt due to cocaine use that's not a
legit it was something that you know he
came out he confronted and he worked on
and he's coming back in their fight in
December first so while the must go
through another test in order to get to
this fight with Joshua and that's going
to be overseas because the draw is too
high to have it in Vegas
I understand you can charge X amount of
dollars for Vegas but yes you're a
packin arenas for 90,000 you having many
concerts before the fight I'm sorry the
level of celebrity that is on display
there is necessary for this sport all
right this sport is fantastic and when
you actually see two men get down for
the nitty-gritty inside that ring it is
something wonderful to see I love the
sport
that's why compact talk is head
so until then Deontay Wilder December
1st the heavyweight division is on a
little bit of a hold right now we have a
great upcoming fights coming stick with
the kid this is combat talk with the
King have a great day
[Applause]
[Music]